a woman has received a federal criminal
conviction for laughing at Attorney
General set Jeff Sessions and she is
facing up to a year in jail you might
remember that during Jeff sessions as
confirmation hearings Alabama Senator
Richard Shelby was talking about
sessions and said that sessions has a
record of quote treating all Americans
equally under the law and that it's
clear and well documented and probably
because of sessions long history with
racial issues his stance on gay marriage
abortion you name it
activist Desiree firuze who was in the
room at the time audibly laughed when
she'll be sung sessions as praises she
was taken out of the room
she was charged and found guilty of
disorderly conduct and now faces up to a
year in jail she told the court quote I
felt it was my responsibility as a
citizen to dissent at the confirmation
hearing of Senator Jeff Sessions a man
who professes anti-immigrant anti LGBT
policies who has voted against several
civil rights measures and who jokes
about the white supremacist terrorist
group the Ku Klux Klan hearings like
these do have rules of decorum so it's
not really a free speech issue per se
but we should at least acknowledge that
it's reasonable to laugh when someone
says this man has a history of treating
all Americans equally because that could
not be further from the truth
multiple times he said favorable things
about the KKK his appointment to a
federal judgeship was rejected in part
because of racial remarks he had made in
the past he's been accused of being
racist towards his black colleagues he
called the n-double-a-cp a communist
unamerican organization he voted against
the Violence Against Women Act he voted
against the program to help women and
minorities start businesses he voted for
banning same-sex marriage he voted
against making LGBT discrimination a
hate crime his rating from the ACLU is a
20 percent his rating from the n-double
a-c-p is a 7 percent his ratings from
the Human Rights Campaign is zero point
zero laughing I think that it would be
legitimate to do more than just laugh if
someone / sings his praises along these
lines and I think the real issue here is
that laughing can be unintentional and
in voluntee
kind of getting into the realm of
thought crimes there I know sometimes
you know if you trip over something in
the studio I just can't help myself I
know maybe it's not the right setting
for me to lash or should I have to do it
I can't I can't help myself and I trip
over things in the studio pretty
frequently actually as a Pat nose-up so
listen I'm hoping that it's sentencing
this woman gets a month probation or
something like that but a year in prison
for laughing at a hearing this would
really be an absolute and total disaster
wouldn't it yeah I think that Jeff
Sessions making the claim that he's all
about human rights and civil rights and
equal rights yeah is one of those things
that's just so little OODA Chris that
you can't help yourself yeah I would
probably laugh as well and yet would I
be able to contain it maybe maybe this
woman did not contain her laughter as
forcefully as she might have been able
to but this is this is crazy this is
absolutely crazy